thanks
what is his mouth doing
is that an accent
why
he's uh he's doing his jared jared leto
performance essentially
burying himself in rubber
but austin butler who speaking of yoga
hosers was in yo gozer's with us um he
looks [ __ ] fantastic and he's singing
it's his voice singing those [ __ ]
songs this trailer looks fantastic and
they're it's like a superhero movie they
even put the captain marvel [ __ ] in
there so he's doing him elvis as
superhero origin story so
you know for a recent [ __ ] elvis uh
convert and stuff i don't know if you
know this [ __ ] made 31 movies in
the span of like two years
[Laughter]
um i was thrilled by this [ __ ]
trailer man i watched it multiple times
uh put it up on the big screen made my
wife watch it and she was like that is
good kevin and then what about her day
um
what did you think
uh i think it's a whole lot of movie i
have no idea what it is really other
than to your point it's a cradle to
grave kind of superhero origin story
right complete with him going to black
churches and feeling the holy ghost and
learning how to sing and dance yup sure
okay let's do that then
um
i'll go see because i like bass lerman
like that dude like he feels true
filmmaker yeah very much so it's in his
blood
um yeah he i mean look there's stuff
that
of his that i haven't watched more than
once but there's stuff of his that i've
watched repeatedly and i still maintain
strictly ballroom is like one of the
greatest films ever made
so i can't wait it looks astounding the
whole time he was like not releasing the
name of the movie
until the trailer and then he was like
elvis yeah i mean come on yeah what was
it gonna be
i mean presley that's true taking care
of business tcb
i suppose the man who made 31 movies in
two years
it's a [ __ ] intriguing title uh what
other trailers dropped i just saw the
last trailer for the batman which comes
out very very soon
um has anybody here seen the batman
because i know they're starting to
screen it coy
we can talk about not having seen it on
the second yeah
maybe not the batman i mean it looks
amazing how could it not be [ __ ] good
uh the latest trailer is is pretty
scintillating it just feels like you
know seven batman by way of seven and
i'm there for it in a big bad way
that happens uh what is it march third
uh probably midnight shows on the third
and then the fourth i think i'm going to
a show on at the
when's the one at the chinese theater
no was that the first the first the fan
event they have an imax fan event yes
and claire
was like do you guys want to sit in the
box blow up claire's spot and just
yeah man apparently
credit's due claire got us like the
penthouse booth at the [ __ ] she's like
you want to watch batman there i was
like
yes
i would like to live in the penthouse
booth at the [ __ ] chinese theater so
we'll be there for the we'll see it
march 1st when do you see it march 2nd
but you've already seen it right yeah
or no you haven't seen you're not even
allowed to say that [ __ ]
i see it's a tricky thing
uh the first trailer for jordan peels
nope yeah that [ __ ] happened at the
super bowl i mean that looks [ __ ]
awesome yeah i i mean all i know is
italians and i didn't know cowboys did
you know that prior to this trailer i
think i did i think i knew that there
was because i think that the original
poster the teaser poster was like clouds
and a [ __ ] kite going up into the
clouds and i thought it had something to
do with abductions and maybe that's the
case maybe it's invasion maybe it's
signs but blacker i don't know either
either way
because
i got a real shyamalan vibe off of the
trailer which is like all mood and all
tension and no content like i don't know
what the movie is but i know that it
looks cool and then it feels cool it has
a vibe it's got a vibe and he's
delivered before so what are the chances
he doesn't deliver with this
when does it come out um july i believe
and uh and the first full doctor strange
trailer drop
[Music]
[Applause]
they gave us what i was hoping they were
going to give us i think back when they
announced it i was like post wanna
vision i was like man if juan is in it i
hope wanda is the villain like i hope
wanda goes full [ __ ] emo despondent
and [ __ ] becomes the villain and it
looks like they're having their cake and
eat it too looks like there's two wandas
like there are two strangers since we're
in the multiverse
so i'm i i love that as much wanda as
you can give me
and if you take her toward a dark
phoenix storyline that would be [ __ ]
nuts and this might be the movie where
she finally says
mutants and then [ __ ] we get the
reverse of you know her going no more
well i mean we're already getting
professor x we're already getting
charles xavier i'll tell you man i i
feel [ __ ] dumb has come man cause i
watched that trailer
i watched that tree the milk of life you
feel us dumb ass let's be honest we're
smarter than come um i felt thomas come
watching this [ __ ] trailer cause i
watched it ten times
and every time i watched it i was like
oh i wonder who the british person is
and then i [ __ ] saw like a piece too
[ __ ] trending and [ __ ] and i was like
oh my god did he die but it's everyone
else on the planet going like i know
that voice that's [ __ ] unmistakable
man that's p stew and i was like it was
and then i went back and listened i was
like
so it sounds like he might be part of
the uh what do they call it the
illuminati the illuminati which means
that the rumors about uh a tom cruise
tony stark variant
could very well be true with him being
on the [ __ ] illuminati as well and
then there's a rumor that uh the guy who
played black bolt
and some mountain yes is might be one of
the illuminati as well i mean
if anybody wants to conjure memories of
that thing
god bless i don't know i think it's
sweet though that you know foggy's just
like all right let's start acknowledging
all these things
yeah i mean i i i look forward to
because reid richards is on the
illuminati
which
rumor has it it's john krasinski playing
reed richards of reed richard's variant
um giving the internet what it's asked
for for a long time but this won't be
three riches richards of the fantastic
four movie so we get to see a lot of it
oh it's such a fun time man these movies
like just when you think like you know i
know a lot of people are like they're so
[ __ ] cookie cutter but just when you
think like all right we know the formula
then they're like here's the multiverse
and now all bets are off because this
person can meet themselves and we could
do all sorts of [ __ ] up stories you
know what would be amazing tell me
wesley snipes as the black panther oh
like the castings that never happened
i just i just dumb as [ __ ] my pants
oh that would be [ __ ] amazing
wouldn't it and so easy to pull off too
[ __ ] i hope they do that i mean if
wesley snaps can be in what we do in the
shadows he could probably show up to be
here was he and what we do yeah they had
a vampire council
for he
[Laughter]
very much so um all right we got news we
got news before news one more ad oh we
have one more sponsor folks and then we
get into the news for those of us
watching at home who are irritated
uh sorry
[Laughter]
but this is gonna happen but there's
always some uh kind soul who puts up
like you know in the comments after the
show's over
when things happen yes there's a time
code ninja who comes aboard and saves
everybody so if you're like i don't
wanna listen to the [ __ ] ad number
one [ __ ] you
um but number two i'm sure somebody will
tell you how to skip it yes but don't
skip on this because we got ourselves a
new sponsor
give it up for the new sponsor man
[Applause]
the good boys and girls at stance
stance yes sock people sock people hat
people just say socks and a hat which
i've used both when i went uh hiking
running today was my 44th day straight
of hiking running
wow
and i
normally i was i haven't been a sock guy
for years and years but in all that
walking i've i've got some planters
fasciitis going on in my left foot so i
bound my foot and i wear socks now and i
got [ __ ] special sneakers and [ __ ]
like that like bart simpson when he had
to get corrective surgery and [ __ ]
um so
i wore their [ __ ] yeah um and it's comfy
as [ __ ] man and the hat was good too did
you know that today was my 28 thousand
423rd day of not hiking
so yeah back in the day sweatpants and
joggers were only to be worn around the
house or the gym that you couldn't
really be seen around town and that
stuff because it wasn't cool
i changed that in the 90s when i started
wearing it to [ __ ] awards ceremony
you're the man and now stance is
following your lead by making a full lot
of sweatpants joggers hoodies and more
that you'll be proud to be seen wearing
whenever they're not just making socks
anymore baby stance parallels they're
moving beyond sucks moving beyond the
sock
stance apparel is all really soft and
comfortable with some really interesting
designs not the same old styles that
everyone else offers stance has all the
active benefits you want with a casual
more creative aesthetic they were good
looking socks yeah not just socks
anymore stance is bringing color comfort
and creativity from toe to head not head
to toe interesting with the launch of
our all-new active apparel line that's
right what started out as radical
reinvention of your sock drawer is
expanding to your entire wardrobe check
out stance's superior soft line of
sweatpants joggers shirts hoodies hats
and more now available in a full range
of fits fabrics prints and fun just
embrace a life of superior comfort kevin
the good folks at stance where's the
website where they gotta go
hold on oh [ __ ] it's on page two it's on
page two
uh what the [ __ ] happened here page
three maybe
they do
stupid thing cut off anyway experience
the signature softness and creativity in
a full line of active apparel lines and
styles from toe to head stance has got
you covered head over to stance.com and
get 15 off your first purchase use promo
code fat man at checkout to apply enjoy
the color and comfort of a life less
ordinary with stance i can vouch for
these stance socks man they were really
[ __ ] nice and the hat was cool not
every [ __ ] like uh toque
works for me but yeah this rolled up and
it actually didn't make me look entirely
old like most [ __ ] winter hats do
so i
i couldn't abide by these good stance
folks man go to stance
dot com folks use the fat man code get
15 off give it up for the new spot
sponsor stance
stance stance
[Applause]
they're making sweat soon i know did you
not want me to read the news oh i
thought that was the ad
i didn't realize that [ __ ] you're
amazing you're done
go home
oh we got news we got some news [ __ ]
yeah we got news mark bernardin came
from the world of news he went and found
some news to tell you tonight give it up
for mark bernard with the news
news
[Applause]
um
first we didn't get to talk about it the
day after or even the weekend after it
premiered but did you like the finale
of the peacemaker season one oh jesus
yes
i loved i loved it so much that i
texted james out of the blue just to be
like
you are on a streak you're doing the
lord's work
go man go like it was just so [ __ ]
beautiful the last shot of that final
episode is so beautifully american
without being dismissive doesn't talk
down to its audience
it's really a [ __ ] portrait of
america and not like the [ __ ]
jingoistic america that we all see in
[ __ ] michael bay movies and [ __ ] but
like the real america like people with
[ __ ] up parents people who live in
[ __ ] trailers people who have eagles
for pets the real [ __ ] america
people are almost as impossibly big as
reacher put those two in a [ __ ] show
man cena and [ __ ] allen what's his
name richard yeah oh my god watch them
[ __ ] fight i'll tell you man one of
those cats should play [ __ ] he-man
they're massive they look the part but
anyway
um i loved it i absolutely adored it and
they announced that it's getting a
season two indeed um thank god uh
people at hbo max have good sense to see
equality when they get it i know they
were racking up social media records and
stuff like that for any hbo max shows
the most talked about
um and what i was very happy to see was
that uh no disrespect to any of the
directors from season one i think all
the episodes were [ __ ] wonderful um
james is going to direct every episode
next season write and direct every
episode
i think i read that
so he's hot committed to it man he
created something special with this show
and uh i'm glad people are catching on
but man
he's got the [ __ ] cast to pull it off
they're all great and especially cena he
he's funny as [ __ ] but he pulled off the
[ __ ] pathos there's a lot of sadness
in that show
um and he was able to pull it off one of
my favorite moments in the entire run
was him [ __ ] dancing to like
a house of pain not house of pain the
band but that [ __ ] song house of pain
is really [ __ ]
sad bittersweet
and then funny as [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
to boot they gave us some justice league
at the end of it spoilers
not the whole justice league but enough
but but enough to free to give the
impression uh that was a big to-do on
twitter
the other day as well because the actors
who portrayed wonder woman and
batman and superman posted
their selfies of them wearing the
outfits and stuff
and uh when you watch the show
aquaman's there and it's literally jason
momoa uh ezra miller is there as flash
and then they have a superman which
looks henry
emery-ish in the sky
and uh henry esque henry and then uh
they've got a wonder woman who looked
you know gallish and then
then there's some space
and
you know you were i when i watched it
never occurred to me that like hey
[ __ ] are missing i was like oh well
[ __ ] obviously two wanted to do it
and they just threw the other two in and
stuff never occurred to me there was
some conspiracy
behind the lack of characters and then
uh
james gunn came out and was like i'm not
at liberty to say why but yeah i was
asked to take batman and cyborg out
now
nobody knows why yeah cyborg as well no
i don't know that he shot cyborg but i i
guess that wasn't even an option
and again maybe i'm putting words in
james gunn's mouth so read what he
actually wrote but
the two justice league members that were
missing were batman who right now is
about to you know go through some
changes in the flash movie and more
earlier than that in the [ __ ] um matt
reeves movie
um and uh
cyborg who was supposed to be in the
flash movie but as we know
is now not in the flash movie um which i
don't know for a fact but seems very
connected to
ray fisher's issues with warner brothers
um so
gunn wanted to do the whole justice
league from what i understand based on
what i read online not from james
himself
and uh you know somebody above him was
like
not so fast you could have these you
can't play with these toys
either way it was amazing the [ __ ]
moe showed up
ezra miller i was not as surprised
because he's cameoed his flash more than
he's played flash in a movie
so he's just keeping the record going
and stuff but you know [ __ ] mamoa is
massive and they're making aquaman 2 and
[ __ ] and still he made the time to be
like i'll come and make a fish [ __ ]
joke yeah absolutely yeah or i'll go
stand next to the the [ __ ] green
screen that's already on the set of the
movie i'm making
probably and and give you two minutes
that's true i think so literal i'm like
they must have all been there
he got her complain yeah happy to see
each other and should know they're
probably four [ __ ] different places
um it was absolutely magical man and i
don't think anybody when they announced
peacemaker was expecting that exact show
uh he was able to do some superficially
funny stuff and then deeply emotional
stuff with a character you know who
has a ridiculous [ __ ] piece of
headgear he made it [ __ ] work in a
great way man i take my hat off to him
man it's a great show
you i could not have foreseen
coming into
i guess the talent of last year
i my bet would have been i am going to
love the star wars show about the
character that i've loved since i was 11
right and dislike the
peacemaker show because i didn't really
like suicide squad right and it ended up
being completely flipped
where i was on board for peacemaker
because peacemaker was a story about a
guy and it was a character piece it had
something to say very trenchant about
the when we are and the where we are in
the world specifically
america it had ambitions it had
ambitions and it had a perspective and
you know the the the last sort of two or
three episodes of that show is very much
about the sort of reckoning
of of a guy in his own past and what
that past has has and how it's
influenced and affected his future and
his present and the fact that he
ultimately shoots that past in the face
spoilers how [ __ ] metal was that
and but even more so like that was
[ __ ] dope but right afterwards like
cena was like an actor enough to pull
off like breaking down and being [ __ ]
emotional my heart broke for the [ __ ]
guy even though you're like kill that
piece of [ __ ] still you're like oh he's
got to [ __ ] live with the fact that
like as much as his father [ __ ]
abused him and treated him like [ __ ] and
[ __ ] tried to literally kill him
he still had love for his only [ __ ]
parent it was so heartbreaking man so
much so that when you get to the last
shot of the series and his [ __ ]
father's sitting there with him he's
always gonna be haunted by that right
then and there i was like [ __ ] hbo
max has all my money until they do
[ __ ] another season of this [ __ ] that
is
that's that's taking something very
simple and saying something kind of deep
with it no very much so i mean that last
shot
is the sort of legacy of this guy which
is i'm a patriot i love my country i've
got the [ __ ] eagle right over here
i'm living in a trailer park that's
painted red white and blue and my dead
racist dad is sitting next to me that i
can't ever escape but i did the thing
which is i shot him in the face
like i've taken responsibility for that
and like i will ride for any show that
says you know what maybe you shoot your
racist dad in the face
it was uh it was a big bold choice for
him to make and i'm glad it seems to be
paying off people seem to really like
the show
i know he took a lot of [ __ ] on twitter
from from some folks like you know based
on
the
justice league making a joke
um because you know they're supposed to
be serious or something but
i think he's got a heart of gold [ __ ]
james and he's
he gets this stuff you know he just
really [ __ ] gets it i
like i'm happy to watch anything the
[ __ ] guy does particularly in this
genre like i like watching james play
with his toys if i went over james's
house and he was like just watch me play
with my toys i would just cuck it out
for two hours
until my mom picked me up and she's like
how'd it go i was like james was amazing
man
you should see what he did with his toys
he's a good dude and has a thing to say
yeah you know why do it unless you're
gonna say a thing
um especially with peacemaker so yeah i
really really dug it because it landed
the emotional beats that i think we were
all kind of looking for so yeah second
season outstanding super happy about
that yes um we also got news that uh
stranger things is finally coming back
after it feels like that's been gone for
a while yeah i mean those kids are not
35 years old
so i'm very curious what the fifth
season is going to look like
when was the last time they did a season
was it pre-pandemic or in the pandemic
oh it's pre-pandemic wow
yeah yeah i mean i don't even remember
when the [ __ ] last episodes came out
but i feel like it was
oh yeah 2019 july 4th 2019. i remember
those days where we could [ __ ] lick
the [ __ ] doorknob and it didn't
matter and [ __ ]
now nobody could lick a doorknob it
[ __ ] sucks
i mean you still can't yeah but if you
really want to run the risk of one of
them variants man and i don't want that
loki variant [ __ ] that
um so yes on may 27th uh the fourth
season is coming back the first chunk of
the fourth season because they are going
to dra draw this out for as long as they
can
um and they have also announced that the
fifth season will be the last season
because again those kids are now getting
mutual funds
for their return that's not right so
they've already announced like this is
it we're gonna be finished yeah yeah
you know and it's it's unclear nobody
knows very much of anything about what
the show is other than we're gonna spend
some time with hopper in russia and
these kids are somewhat scattered to the
winds where i think some of them have
moved to california
um i love that david harbor
i think he's so charismatic
i love him as an actor i mean i don't
know what he's like as a human but he
seems like a good guy
um and he was a great host on snl
i mean not like you really host but like
he was funny as [ __ ] on snl he's got
[ __ ] funny chops
um so yeah that's the gym that's the
move on stranger things are you excited
to see it again
uh are you that guy like everybody else
was all right [ __ ] here we go
it's where the internet's gonna be like
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
i have never seen a single episode of
stranger things
listen the rocket took off i'm don't
applaud i'm not saying like and that
makes me middle right the rocket took
off and then it felt like it was too
late to [ __ ] get on when everybody
was like this show's [ __ ] brilliant
and and i haven't gotten around to it i
honestly thought during the pandemic
that we would do a deep dive and stuff
but so many other great shows came out
so i i love you know what i know about
it and the things i've seen the trailers
and pieces of the show and whatnot but
i've not
that of the takes you could have had
that is not so bad bro you're out of
your [ __ ] mind one of the least hot
takes on the planet is i don't know
spider-man could have been one of the
[ __ ]
10 nomination best picture and
[ __ ] were like burn them burn
that [ __ ] dick all i'm saying is you
could have said i didn't like it i saw
it didn't dig it i haven't seen it
though but that would have been worse
the iso
oh trust me they'll find a way to be
like i mean they'll do what they do yeah
[ __ ] smith [ __ ] refuses to watch the
best show on tv because he's a [ __ ]
dick and he made [ __ ] masters of the
universe what an [ __ ]
but i haven't watched it yet man i i do
look forward to watching it and maybe
now is the time when does season five
begin what's up may season four uh point
one
four point two will be in july uh i love
finn wolfhard i think he's awesome i
love the fact that you have like some
kind of murder board of internet
responses to anything that you say up in
your house and you're like it's not
gonna say this this will happen
this is this is not a murderboard it's a
bingo board man you can literally play
bingo by the [ __ ] programmed
responses that bots throw my way and not
just bots i'm sure it's real people who
were like go [ __ ] yourself silent bill
and i'm like well it's bob but whatever
banff hey
[Applause]
i'll uh i'll one-up you on the not
watching stranger things so i watched
this this would be amazing if you were
like i've never seen star wars
i'm like holy [ __ ] what i've just read
all of wikipedia and i would know it all
i just think it sounds cool
what is it what have you not seen so we
watched you better not say clerks
[ __ ]
i i watched the first episode with
jen
and she was like oh my god we have to
watch this together this seems so good
but she's like it's really scary so we
have to watch it like we can't watch it
before we go to bed
that was when the first
episode came out like
seven years ago or whatever it was i
haven't watched it since
that happened again with loki i haven't
watched loki yet because i promise you
[ __ ] piece of human [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you and i
call you friend
of all the marvel shows that like to
like
not slept on but not gotten to yet
like that
that would be i would say you're okay
like it's not but you will need some of
it for multiverse of madness probably
well it was i i'm not saying i don't
like the show i like the show but of all
the [ __ ] shows that one
took its time
jen was like i love loki you have to
wait to watch it for me and i'm like
okay
and it's been a year and i'm still
waiting and it's not on the schedule
like it
just is i love that jen is [ __ ]
hawkeye from laza mohegans and you're
madeline stowe and she's like don't
watch it no matter what occurs they will
be back for you and watch it together
you're like but what
when though
stay alive i will find you
that's very keanu
stay alive stay alive whoa i will find
you
stay alive
i will find you remember he had that
weird accent like he always does the
weird accents but he found like this is
what the kentucky accent would sound
like and [ __ ] the pier
kentucky
yeah i don't know what's happening in
that corner who's saying horseshit is it
andrew
and he's from kentucky andrew's uh
objecting to the to the to daniel is
this your hot take on daniel day lewis's
accent
from [ __ ] leslie mohicans i think he
said like he wasn't doing current
kentucky he was doing
eight what year did that why is he doing
any kentucky i thought that was in the
[ __ ] like north west northeast of
was that in kentucky
yeah but i thought it was i
but but i thought that's why should they
go into kentucky that's how he said it
but doesn't that take in like northern
new york isn't that like upper canada
isn't that kentucky was in a [ __ ]
what are we talking about
where are we
last of the mohicans i assumed it took
place in kentucky because he said
kentucky a lot in the movie he was like
kentucky
hey so uh maybe that's maybe that's
where they were going
like maybe they were like destination
kentucky or something like that [ __ ]
felt like the south like that all felt
like
what the f i probably shot it in
vancouver
but i i i'm shocked you remember as much
as you do about last of the mohicans
because i've watched the end of that a
lot like the last 20 minutes of latin
americans is phenomenal you watch it
because you're like i want to see if she
stayed alive and he did find her no i
don't see that dude fall off the [ __ ]
cliff and and the the other dude yeah
come with a grand green is [ __ ] santa
trying to protect his son his son gets
killed that shit's good dude but nothing
beats reacher curbing some [ __ ]
you know it man nothing's just
satisfying i'm just i'm just small towns
just shut down stop making all the
[ __ ] they do believe me i watched
feature i was like [ __ ] clerks three
this is the end like this is
entertainment we finally figured out how
to make the perfect [ __ ] piece of
entertainment
all right shut it all down yeah we don't
need
now like why is kevin james talking [ __ ]
like it's not kevin james it's the other
kevin no like costner they're like no
the low key [ __ ] kid it's reacher all
around that's all we're doing now i just
signed a uh clerk's porn parody i forgot
that they did this
if you've never seen it seek it out
online and [ __ ] um
as the guy who uh made clerks i was uh
titillated to see that they uh actually
did a porn version of it but you know
they didn't make up a fun name and [ __ ]
like edward penis you know just it's
just porn
it could have been like 37 dicks
could have literally been leave off the
us and just make it clerks you know with
the x and then that would have been a
parody title if they made it cucks
it has been uh kind of it has been a
very weird yeah they could have done
cuffs see um it's uh been a long time
since i've held the porno like
yeah um but i forgot that they have the
most graphic [ __ ] photos on the back
i mean they don't care it's so crazy man
like sex acts where you're like jesus
christ yeah youtube they'll take us off
we can't even [ __ ] show the trailer
to the batman without [ __ ] being
knocked off man let me run the batman
didn't we try to show a trailer for
something i was invited he tried to show
the masters of the universe trailer they
kicked us off youtube
that might have not been because of
ownership they might have been like you
ruined he-man
they've editorialized yeah that might
have been one of that
anyway anyway uh there's a story they
broke i think yesterday that captivated
my imagination fire which is john
carpenter
master filmmaker master filmmaker 74
year old director of some of the best
genre movies that have ever been made
tall too
is he i think so really he's one of them
tall guys no anybody's one of them tall
guys
about that that's pretty i mean
taller than me
taller than me that's what i meant to
say i mean if if you're short
everybody's a tall guy so
that's true yeah he's no allen richton
though he ain't no reacher but yeah he's
got some height uh he's declared that he
would like to make a sequel to the thing
and [ __ ] hopefully
hollywood parked a truck of money at his
door and said oh [ __ ] go
i don't know man he an interview with
the hollywood reporter who had sort of
asked him if there's any other movie
filmography wishes that had a sequel
because a lot of them have there's the
98th halloween sequel i think that just
came out it's true um he said i would
like to do a sequel to the thing or a
continuation something like that but i
don't know see there are a lot of things
in this world i don't know does he do it
with kurt russell or no
i mean he has to he doesn't have to but
at the end of the movie you just don't
know what happens so if he makes a
sequel and kurt russell's in it we know
what happens or both of those dudes are
in it
him and keith david or kurt russell
starts off the movie in the first like
10 minutes so he's in all the marketing
and [ __ ] but then he is the [ __ ]
thing
[Laughter]
um so nobody's stepping up to be like
we'll give you that money who did
the thing back in the day is that
universal it's universal
universal should be fast and furiously
writing this [ __ ] do to check
thank you nice thank you here's my hot
take for the week film twitter's gonna
be like shut your [ __ ] mouth yoga
hoser
yeah only if he does the soundtrack
what's that
if he does any soundtrack i want more
john carpenter soundtracks [ __ ] yeah
he's doing albums now
just like creating music
he should he was always gifted i had the
[ __ ] i mean
it's not the most popular but i had the
halloween three soundtrack on [ __ ]
vinyl and played it all the time to a
point where my parents are like should
we call a psychiatrist
and i was like no i just like it man
it's cool that synth and [ __ ] yeah he's
very gifted
um
all right well i think we all co-sign on
yes we're all on board
i don't think anybody's going like what
a dumb idea
especially returning with the master
himself
speaking of potentially dumb ideas
um
do you want a wonder twins movie because
i don't know if i want a wonder twins
movie
i saw this is happening i'm you know i'm
down i'll watch it as long as they're in
the right outfits i'll watch it man i
got a low bar i'm like does that look
like my childhood done
but hbo max seems hell bent on giving us
a wonder twins movie i'll take it uh
it's on hbo max on hbo max i got it
anyway so i'll watch it the lowest of
bars i mean it's not like [ __ ] like i
mean there's no barrier in it's not like
i'm like well i don't know if i want to
leave the house to watch the wonder
twins i can literally [ __ ] watch the
wonder twins pause it jerk off take a
[ __ ] come back make some hummus and
watch the rest of the wonder twins
and that really improves any [ __ ]
movie man
that was the most michael pena thing
i've ever heard you said
yo let me get this straight what am i
gonna do
jerk off make some hummus not much of
one turmoil if you're allowed to do the
voice right i'm not doing the voice i'm
just talking real fast fair enough
what else we got uh let me see you are
not a big star trek movie person no
wrong i am a big star trek movie person
not a big star trek tv show person fair
so i know the movies chapter and verse
why
they're making star trek four oh i know
this
well then by all means my friend taking
runs snuck out of nowhere recently they
just and chris pines coming back one of
my favorite [ __ ] actors on the planet
that dude is pure joy man have you ever
seen a bad chris pine performance he
always brings something to it man oh
he's [ __ ] dope he even [ __ ] like
he was the high highlight of wonder
woman 84 i thought he was so damn
charming that [ __ ] one line alone
where he's like
like uh do people have parachutes now
[Laughter]
so [ __ ] charming so he was a
wonderful captain kirk where he didn't
do a shatner impression but he [ __ ]
embodied
young kirk without doing
a shatner uh so i'll watch this dude
[ __ ] do anything first time i noticed
him smoking aces he [ __ ] kills ben
affleck and then he's sitting on his
chest and he's making him talk i was
like this kid's genius so i'm game i'm
down for more star trek what was the
last one they did uh star trek beyond
was that when they were riding
motorcycles yeah [ __ ] that was good i've
liked all the star trek movies man you
know the first one was a little tough
the very first one that was just [ __ ]
porn if you liked the enterprise
[Music]
20 minutes of showing off the ship where
you're like come on man my [ __ ] this
is post millennium falcon move on
not for those folks not at all but um
i do dig those star trek pictures so i'm
i'm down i've seen every one of them in
a theater it was news
to both all of us as an audience as well
as to the cast who did not know that
there was going to be a star trek iv
it's another like hurriedly making deals
to lock everybody down [ __ ] you wanna
talk about privilege could you imagine
like i wonder what i'm gonna do this
year and somebody's like here's a star
trek you know like well there was that
zachary quinto is just like [ __ ] hey
i'm back here we go i'm sure he does
other things but you know i know him as
spock primarily
bam oh hey now bath man is coming in to
tell us like the internet went ape [ __ ]
on you because you said zachary kinto
hasn't worked since [ __ ] spock that's
not what i said by the way i just want
to know the over under we got the whole
it's not khan it's khan like we got like
star trek two kind of do we get whales
in four [ __ ] like there's some sort
of whale nuclear wessels um transparent
aluminum do they do it i don't know man
like i was just watching that final
trailer for [ __ ] the batman tonight
and i was like boy this looks [ __ ]
dark and original and [ __ ] weird and
[ __ ] cool
and then i was like and it's got the bat
and the cat and the penguin i was like
wait a second they did this movie in
1992
it was called batman returns it was the
same [ __ ] cast it was the bat the cat
and the [ __ ] penguin they didn't have
the riddler in it though that's the
[ __ ] bonus that's the one-upmanship
yes um i think it's it has been
revealed i guess that this is not going
to be the quentin tarantino version of
star trek
because once upon a time quentin
tarantino was 100 gonna write a star
trek yeah we i remember that what
happened um i think that the minds of
star trek were like no
wait what
yeah somebody nixed that i just thought
he lost interest i mean i think that it
was
as it had been revealed it was going to
be a a
if you've ever seen the classic trek
episode piece of the action
where it's like time no it's just we
went to a mob planet that's it because
you know again 60 star trek was what
sets are lying around what makeup what
costumes do we have i know gangsters
that episode is literally they go to a
planet that looks like 1920s gangsters
yeah
yeah
wow
star trek i know that look i can vouch
for the movies i'll stick to that yeah
so is that a good episode um it's fine
you know it's silly as [ __ ]
but it's like oh all right sure i want
to see
william shatner say stuff like hey uh
paluca
give me the heater am i saying it right
bones yeah you're saying it right like
it's lots of
weird like trying to pretend to be
earthquakes something that they uh
repeated a little bit in uh in star trek
four where he's like double dumb ass on
you
yes
um i think that was probably an excuse
for quentin tarantino to write somebody
saying the n-word on star trek
and we just lost the internet again
farewell my friend
um but yeah star trek four is happening
they want it to be out next december
so they're a reason to live
another reason to live i have one more
reason for you to live sir that means
[ __ ] uh zoey's gonna be in it too
right uh yeah no they're trying to get
everybody she's fantastic i'll watch her
in anything
[ __ ] hold on man i'm on a zoe saldana
thing i'm doing hold your [ __ ] horses
remember when she was like no jake sully
an avatar
she's coming back she'd be doing it
again in the next avatar movie i mean
yeah she's great and she's great in star
trek she's [ __ ] it's great and
everything man it's great in guardians
remember when she said that line you
guys
that was great do you remember anything
else about avatar no you don't
um all right keep going um
i was just going to say
just name drop friend of the show uh mr
shackman is directing that yes that's
shackman is directing what wanderface
star trek four matt shack is directing
star trek
four [ __ ] he did a great job who
wanted it
[Applause]
um
all right what else we got um another
reason for you to live
is that uh dandy johnny williams
is returning to the star trek fold to
write the theme
for kenobi
star wars
john williams yes is coming back to do
the kenobi theme yes
he hasn't
he hasn't done any like he didn't do the
mandalorian and he didn't do boba fett
or anything like that no he's only ever
done movies i believe well look at this
man
so he did
uh one two three four five six seven
eight nine and then he did the solo
theme for solo but he didn't do the
whole movie and he's never done any of
the video game stuff right it's all been
interpretations of the interpretations
gotcha but yes i'm so [ __ ] excited to
hear more john william star wars music
because again the most important man in
movies um coming to tv so makes me happy
the last news item is one that i think
you've already talked about at length
i've mentioned more than once
we haven't got to talk about on the show
because it happened just after we
recorded the last one
rest in peace ivan reitman
yes
um
look it [ __ ] sucks uh to lose anybody
particularly somebody who
had a [ __ ] run of of wonderful films
that shaped a lot of our childhoods you
know yeah our parents and our friends
shape our childhood as well but the
things we watch and the things we love
and re-watch particularly those of us
from that generation that didn't have
every option on the planet and [ __ ]
didn't live with faces and phones we
lived with our faces in our [ __ ] tv
screens ladies and gentlemen where we
watched our movies over and over again
most of them by ivan reitman um i he the
man made a triumvirate of movies which
uh infected my dna and you could see the
influence of his work in in mine uh he
did him back to back almost meatballs
stripes
and ghostbusters like those you know the
anti-heroes of those three movies which
would be tripper
uh john winger and peter venkman i don't
get to randall without those characters
the person who's the smartest guy in the
room but not doing as well as you would
think he would being as clever as they
are and stuff um an archetype that he
captured expertly on film uh with the
help of powerhouse [ __ ] bill murray
um the one positive thing and i don't
even know if you could say it's positive
but the one silver lining
to his death is that he did get to see
ghostbusters after life which was such a
[ __ ]
beautiful
memorial
fan film to the original from father
to son um you know
jason brought us
egon back you know gave us one of my
favorite moments in a movie of the last
10 years where it's just like
now that's what [ __ ] movies are all
about man the power to do something that
[ __ ] fantastic put them all together
again for one last [ __ ] time really
beautiful stuff and he did it i remember
when he came over my house he was doing
a podcast and [ __ ] and as soon as the
podcast was over he was like i want to
show you something and he showed me the
[ __ ] teaser thing that they had shot
where you just saw the back of the
[ __ ] uh the ectomobile and i was like
what the [ __ ] and he was like you cannot
[ __ ] say anything he's like but like
you know for years i ran from my
father's legacy to be my own person he's
going but like
i i think i want to do this one and i
think i want to do it with my dad and he
did he got to make that [ __ ] movie
with his dad his dad got to see that
movie and then sadly passed away so i
texted him when i saw that instantly and
i was like look
i lost my dad almost 20 years ago it
never gets better and my dad did not
make ghostbusters so like
please man like fo mourn him every damn
day we lost a titan you were lucky kid
and stuff um
it's he's he was easily
uh one of the best of us canadian makes
him even better and [ __ ] like that
czechoslovakian yes that's right like i
think his parents he was born
he was so he's like first generation he
came over as well he's he's not even the
first one
wow
um yeah man [ __ ] i'll never forget
seeing meatballs and i was a child when
i saw that movie but what an impact it
made
because you know anti-heroes is showing
you know [ __ ] lovable losers you'd
only done that in like the bad news
bears as a kid that was the only one i
remember saying
um this was a whole different catalyst
kettle of fish and for what 10 years
[ __ ] straight that dude had hit after
hit and even the movies he did which
weren't like massive hits i'm a big fan
of legal eagles which is a movie he did
like right after ghostbusters and the
whole world was like is it gonna be as
big as ghostbusters and it wasn't but
like
it was it was real no ghosts yeah they
were missing ghosts they had robert
redford they had deborah winger they had
daryl hannah as well but um
what a wonderful [ __ ] filmmaker he
was jason told me
uh
not that podcast but one of the earlier
podcasts he came over to do
uh he said the best piece of advice his
father ever gave him as a filmmaker was
make as many movies as possible he said
because don't be choosy just [ __ ]
make movies never stop he's gone my
mistake
was after ghostbusters i always waited
for a script as good as ghostbusters and
he's like and the [ __ ] fact of the
matter is ghostbusters doesn't come
along but once in a lifetime he's gone
so i wish i had made more at this point
you know just good bad indifferent it
wouldn't matter
um i found that rather profound man and
from the day he told me that i started
going like yeah
quantity not quality that's what i'll do
i
probably took the wrong message from it
mark but well regardless um but yes ivan
reitman thank you for for
giving a fat kid so many things to do uh
all throughout his childhood uh with his
family um
by his side i saw every one of those
movies in my family man and that's how
you learn
who the people you love are you watch
art with them um that's [ __ ]
shows you who they really are when
they're immersed in something where
they're not thinking about you or
thinking about portraying themselves or
any of that [ __ ] i saw my father for
years as my father you know revered him
as like dad and [ __ ] but he's a [ __ ]
statue [ __ ]
roman god of some sort and [ __ ] but in
the movies when he would take me to the
movie theater that's where i got to see
who my father really was i saw the [ __ ]
that made him laugh saw the [ __ ] that
moved him that thrilled him that got him
excited that made him talk in a way i'd
never heard him talk before and [ __ ]
like a kid with enthusiasm it showed me
uh my father crying like for the first
time in my life my father wasn't afraid
you know it was dark in a movie theater
so i guess he wasn't [ __ ] afraid to
get emotional at a flick and and you
know that's an impact
moment for a child to be like it's okay
like you can you know you're always told
don't cry and here's my old man [ __ ]
crying it's some [ __ ] that happened to
[ __ ]
garp in the world according to garth and
i was like god damn it man like that's
how you learn who people are and stuff
and so i got to learn a lot about who my
dad was who my mom was who my brother
and sister were the things they found
funny the things that meant stuff to
them watching those movies side by side
with them as well as my [ __ ] friends
man repeatedly can't imagine how many
times i've watched ghostbusters with my
family with my friends with myself with
my [ __ ] second family when i got
married and had a [ __ ] kid and stuff
like that
um same with [ __ ] stripes same with
meatballs honestly not two years go by
where i don't re-watch those movies
because they were so
[ __ ] formative for me so
we lost a great one but [ __ ] you know
rather than lament the fact that he's
gone let's celebrate the fact that he
ever [ __ ] lived and gave us some of
the best movies that we ever [ __ ] saw
give it up for ivan wright and ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
yeah i just i just want to give a little
love to some of the movies that that
don't get the love that don't get the
love i will ride or die for kindergarten
cop
oh [ __ ] it's not a tumor it's not the
tumor
boys have a penis girth have a vagina
i think it's so sweet and i and and the
transformation that he puts
schwarzenegger through like that's when
schwarzenegger becomes a human being to
the eyes of a movie going public he had
just been the terminator and conan and
like the giant person he got to show a
sense of humor he got to be funny and he
got to be sweet he got to be light
because that's what you do with a giant
hulking person you struggle with kids no
no you [ __ ] put him in a small town
let him curb people to death
that's what you do with a big man
have you learned nothing
and dave i love i [ __ ] love dave dave
i hate politics but i [ __ ] love dave
it's the sweetest gentlest movie so
wonderful just about a good dude trying
to do good things and he cast like
somebody who like is a wonderful actor
and has worked and stuff like that but
like he went for the least obvious guy
kevin kline who was like one of the most
likable [ __ ] lovable performers on
the planet and [ __ ] um very versatile
and what and what not and if you were
making that movie today you'd be like
you know get tom holland or something
like that but they went for
like the guy who made the most sense the
guy who would actually be
lovable in the role a president who went
from like you know the real guy was a
piece of [ __ ] and then this guy comes in
subs for him and like changes everything
you want to talk about pure
[ __ ] hollywood fluff and fantasy it's
very frank capra-esque but what a
beautiful [ __ ] movie i love that film
dave if you haven't seen it kids
go check it out it's so worth watching
even if you put it on you're like
washington [ __ ] this like it ain't that
movie at all although frank langella is
pretty [ __ ] scary he really is yeah
and ving rhames is as cuddly as you're
ever going to oh
oh bro i'm going to cry i'm thinking
about dave
took a bullet for you
[Laughter]
such a beautiful moment and that's being
raised
public fiction yeah
um but yeah it's a lovely lovely movie
and that's it man that's all the news
that's it why do i have a license who
gave me their license
oh it's a passport card who's what am i
to do am i to sign it
you might not get into other countries
if i avoid it with my signature
fair enough i'll put it i'm you know i
don't i'm i'm going to make the call on
this
and it still works
all right
but if you get stopped at the border
that's on you
um that's all the news
that's all the news ladies and gentlemen
that's all the news give it up for mark
you got the news
[Applause]
um all right man so once we do the news
then what we head into the [ __ ]
do you ask of thee these questions three
this is always [ __ ] q a i've got a
couple uh
i did some research
uh first off how
you yeah i was gonna say you watching
chad how's it going chat was pretty good
there was some uh some stuff i liked in
there um
at the beginning of the show when mark
was disparaging something or other
they crowned him
i believe that's the subtitle of the
show batman beyond colin mark disparages
something
for the record i find that you like
things more than you dislike things i do
i see you every week and i don't get the
overriding impression that you hate
everything at all in fact i think you
like most things yeah no the problem is
is that i i sometimes i dislike the one
thing that other people think that i
should like yeah um and it happens to be
a tv show that i just happen to dislike
a lot
but it's just the one thing like i
cannot like boba fett it's just one show
but for seven weeks in a row i'm still
not liking it so i think the repetition
of that gives a false impression
i honestly did not have the um [ __ ]
hard time that everybody had with it my
bar is [ __ ] low and i watched that
show and i'm like i would never have
thought of any of those things even the
man that spun around real fast to take a
[ __ ] shot
that is pure like robert rodriguez like
anybody been alive watching robert
rodriguez movies since he started
without mariachi somebody always spins
around and fires a gun and that like
took twitter's imagination by storm
where people like never let this guy
near star wars i'm like are you [ __ ]
crazy i i will say i also would not have
imagined any of the things that happened
in that show
oh you're such a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i did i i enjoyed it man when's the next
star wars show does anybody know what it
is uh it's kenobi did they say what the
date is banff man 25th oh star wars day
well that makes a [ __ ] ton of sense how
many episodes
six i'll let somebody else answer yeah i
was gonna say he beat you over there
you're the new banff man
six episodes that's more like somebody
knows and can't say
is that right that's that look um secret
invasion is also meant to be six
episodes
they're lowering them remember how many
episodes was wanda
uh
six
was it
it was eight
was more
falcon winter soldier was six
i guess the sweet spot is like six
chicks it's what would have been a movie
that we cut into separate pieces would
it be six no three three three so it's a
movie and change movie and change extent
plus
a movie plus yeah
um all right
enough about us did i sign everything i
did oh [ __ ] can we before we do the
questions can we do
this big box
is there a baby in it yeah [ __ ] yeah and
it's been suffocating this whole time
we had more important things to talk
about is it the baby of freedom it is
man it's a baby of [ __ ] peace right
there um who wants to carry this box
over to the front
uh there you go well done
right up here we could set it and let's
put it uh
while he's walking the chat dubbed mark
tonight mark's side
the mark said mark s-e-i-d like oh
mark's side
um spin it this way where the so you can
see the piece symbol there you go and
then right isn't there a piece symbol on
all sides yeah no not all sides slide
back slide back slide back keep sliding
bang you did it give it up for him
ladies and gentlemen he helped
uh so uh hbo max sent out this
ridiculously wonderful
uh peacemaker uh premier here jc you
might need to i can pull it back here
well they could see it on the screen as
that's right
um
uh let's see what's in it folks
this says declassified prepared for task
force x
subject peacemaker and close you will
find a collection of items deemed
declassified by us government nat sec
your colleagues have received similar
packages which you should use at your
liberty to alert the populace of this
man's arrival christopher smith and date
of birth is black line and here is known
as sochi it's everyone in the show and
stuff
that's what's in the top
uh
first up is a
hoodie
a hoodie that says
peace at any cost and it's got
peacemaker right on it we'll put that
over there
and the rest is just stuffing no
uh let's see
oh of course there's a food component
because generally when they send these
they're always like you know you like to
eat [ __ ]
so there's hot cheetos and there's some
hot cheetos oh
nice oh my god man yeah hot cheetos like
judo master oh [ __ ] you're right who's
eating chips
see i'm dumb as [ __ ] dude i can't
never figure [ __ ] out um they've got
amazing albums there's a d.o album last
in line
ozzy osbourne [ __ ] uh
double vinyl set right there uh let's
see that's
smart non-theme right because he was way
into
[ __ ] is that is there a helmet in
there metal there's another
ozzy osbourne blizzard of oz
yeah we'll find out yeah
it depends who answers while we give
[ __ ] out to everybody here what's this
flag
oh it's a peace flag yeah it's a peace
flag yeah it's got a little picture it's
american flag but it's got peace symbol
instead of stars
um
this is a dc peacemaker book by garth
ennis
that they've included a black label book
i think that's the one where they like
tie his dad into like he's like a nazi
war criminal wasn't it i think he was
the one that told that story free
three-month subscription to
dc universe infinite that's where you
can read a bunch of comics and stuff
like that who reads comics anybody want
this you into it
you get your own right you give it back
to him man three months some free
comments from dc
uh
i could oh [ __ ] what's that oh [ __ ] well
i want to make sure that there's nothing
touch it small there's a lot of [ __ ]
stuff and my my this is going to sound
braggy but i've been i'm this is day
three of a fast so i'm at 80 hours of a
fast right now and i've been hiking
running like every [ __ ] day so my
ring keeps slipping off
and i don't want to lose it in this box
so i'm gonna put it here on the bar
remind me
dude yes
i don't want to be responsible for that
no i just i don't want to lose in this
box and then i'll be like what did you
do with kevin last night
nothing jen tell my wife he made me take
my ring off and [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yes
what a good idea man like when i saw the
shirt i was like that's an awfully big
box for a [ __ ] shirt but holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah really sonic boom do you want to
try it on no my head is too big for this
i know my head try it bamf man you look
like you have a peacemaker-sized head
see if that works don't cut yourself or
is it for children
baby peacemaker oh [ __ ] there's more i
don't know this is gonna
oh
look at that
it's eagley
[Applause]
um the eagle was absolutely [ __ ]
adorable on that show
and looked really big don't do it
be very careful j.c let's do it
again for children it might say on it
don't wear it dumbass it's
it's an ice bucket not an actual helmet
and then there's a big box within the
box
i might need help with this there's a
mystery inside of a there it is oh
there's more stuff jesus stuff
this is a [ __ ] cool ass peacemaker
multi dc multiverse figure
and when you collect them all you can
build looks like gorilla gro no king
shark holy [ __ ]
um that's dope all right here we go
let's get this box up
hold on
i know what that is
it's a record player
oh it's a record player
a victrola uh bluetooth record player
because they included albums that's
[ __ ] dope um now
i appreciate all this stuff and we will
distribute it uh for the folks here uh
who i'm sure are all peacemaker fans
but
you had me at hello you don't
need to spend this kind of money why do
you think they do this mark um so that
you will unbox it on the televisions
but what like they need help like
everyone's watching the show already
because there's a budget that needs to
be spent otherwise they don't get the
budget again next time is that what it
comes down to nine times out of ten we
got a line item that needs to be filled
i'm glad man um okay let's start giving
out some [ __ ]
is that what you would like
well do we want wait wait hold on hold
on
[Applause]
he gave me 50 bucks man well all right
i'm making some money off this
peacemaker i'm gonna [ __ ] text james
gunn and be like keep making that show
all right should we should we make it
part of the q a process [ __ ] no
we'll just do separate peacemaker black
label comic book
damn going right there your am one up
all you
you're welcome
um the piece uh it's not a peacemaker
but it's just an american peace flag we
should all be supporting the idea of
peace no hands went up you [ __ ]
over there bam here we go
oh right to kentucky can you give it to
her nate thank you um
who wants some flaming cheetos
more hands for flaming cheetos than
peace
what's [ __ ] wrong with this country
where am i going i saw a hand go up over
there
the air took it
um
i get we i guess we can't split up the
records in the record player should they
all go together yeah i think so fair
enough all right let's start here uh the
hoodie is actually nice and soft but
what size is it
um it's an xl hoodie
uh-oh we got some dudes back here
well well
here i got an idea we had three birthday
people
byron
mike
and steve
so
byron
this is xl would you fit in this
happy birthday byron give it up for
byron
[Applause]
mike are you a fan of eagles
you want the helmet
listen to this [ __ ] man i'm like you
want an eagle she's like mike wants the
helmet
i mean take her everywhere she's a
negotiator right there
um it's mike's birthday does mike
deserve the helmet ladies and gentlemen
come get your helmet peacemaker
[Applause]
activate bossy wife um
well done well done
uh we'll save eagle uh steven silva
what
for your birthday i got your record
player and three metal albums
come get your [ __ ]
the only drawback is you have to come
get it though man it has somebody send
somebody but whatnot there you go
somebody's going to help you out happy
birthday stephen all right we covered
all the birthday boys
left is an eagle
[Music]
the peace flag got no interest
but the stuffed symbol of freedom did
how interesting
um how do we do how do we decide who
gets eagerly
should we throw in the air and let
everybody go for it and [ __ ]
thunderdome for eagley
how about um [ __ ] how do we figure this
out
i just you can always make it yeah the
best question gets eagerly to be fair
it's not like a dc brand eagley eagle
it's just a
it's a random ass eagle it's very nicely
done it's by the douglas people the
cuddle toy but yeah it's not officially
eagerly so
it's just an eagle so let's see where
will it fly to how far can you make it
fly well
i got no arm i have no body strength
you're looking for it in a big bad way
i i can try i guess
i just gave away a bunch of [ __ ] now you
want nfts as well
um all right how do we figure out who
gets the eagle
well i mean that's not figuring it out
how do we how do we do it
there's tears in the corner
there's some big love over there why
tears over this
there you go an animal lover wins give
it up for the animal lover ladies and
gentlemen all right launch it
[Music]
um okay we're done with that [ __ ]
we thank the good folks at hbo max for
giving us that big box of wanderfall
and uh some people in here are
especially [ __ ] thankful because they
walked away with some cool [ __ ] well
done everybody
people really win on whatever the show's
called
um all right time for those questions
right jc
people really win on fasting with kids
yes where are we who are fasting and
furious
okay we got q a questions uh but someone
in chat i lost their name
said uh
about kentucky and the last mohicans
uh
the book the last of the mohegans took
place in what is now upstate new york
but makes mention
[Laughter]
makes mention
of going to kentucky which at the time
was an algonquin word for bloody hunting
grounds
so they're not really going to kentucky
no well i think they're going to what
will become kentucky because it's a
bloody hunting ground
or it could be any other bloody hunting
around that that's true if that's the
name of that word
oh [ __ ] is here a rare appearance by
andrew give it up for andrew ladies john
[Applause]
kentucky the translation andrew is from
kentucky no
the translation of kentucky is the dark
and bloody ground that's pretty metal
you know what's interesting
is that no i'm from illinois nobody from
illinois is like when somebody mentions
illinois like i don't run out of a
closet
[Applause]
[Laughter]
god damn it man andrew like for once
he's like you know what i'm gonna
[ __ ] participate too
and banff man just smacks him down get
back in your [ __ ] hole you guys get
your corner
trivia but i know a thing and i can't
say my thing [ __ ] all of you
oh man
this world animals are equal but some
animals are more equal than others
apparently
orwellian world uh all right questions
okay
uh first question from andrea g
all right come on andrea g's coming up
give it up for her
[Applause]
hey how are you i'm good i'm what didn't
realize that i would be my equestrian
week pick but i'm glad it was you
weren't prepared huh no but and i guess
do you want a drink
i had a couple
look i'm good you're like i'm there
buddy
but yeah in honor of peacemaker what
other comic book character could pull
off an 80s rock opening number
what a great question first let's give
it up for that opening of peacemaker yes
i never skipped it and i watched it each
and every every time it was so [ __ ]
joyous um
but what character
what are the characters like which uh
what comic book character what combo
character could have a cool
uh well
dazzler that's for sure it'd be disco
i'm okay with that and that's 70s well
did she say it had to be any
specifically you said 80s yes uh yes i
did say 80s rock numbers i mean disco
went into like 81 that's when it died
fine
yeah
you
i feel like
dazzler you can get all the [ __ ] like
great songs like a whole donna summer
soundtrack like let's dance the last
dance
man
i'm surprised your answer is not dazzler
as well to be honest with you i thought
we'd be on the same page it could have
been dazzler um
instead i'm gonna go the beyonder
um and some good duran duran
oh i didn't know we got to pick the
artist
i mean i'm playing to win
so you just want to come correct hungry
like the wolf feels like it's just built
to be a [ __ ] opening credit song so
the beyonder but is there multiple
people in the cast or is it just the
beyond or bogian i mean it would be
ultimately like secret wars but oh [ __ ]
there you go there's your answer it's
secret wars like when they finally do
secret wars the whole opening sequences
they're all dancing and [ __ ] yeah
like i i can't take it no no it's it's
it's two tribes go to war
oh from frankie yeah that's that's the
song i'll take that um all right couple
of lame answers but that's as good as
this
but guess what
you win a prize come get it you're gonna
get not only a sign
fat man beyond poster man as done by the
great dark nate gonzalez but more
importantly well not more importantly
but [ __ ] cooler than that and i'm not
cooler than that i'm sorry
really should have practiced in addition
how about that better um you're gonna
get two
40x
tickets man thanks to the good folks at
40x and our friend brett deacon have you
ever watched a movie in 4dx yet oh my
god
are you in for such an experience the
chair vibrates so be careful uh give it
up for a ladies and gentleman she won
[Applause]
i still got bits of peacemaker all over
me
from that box
all right there's one down two to go
this is uh
as yusuf yosef
come on up get on up what did you seth
[Applause]
as
ask joseph joseph
which one is it oh aj joseph
give it up for aj his real name aj
[Applause]
how are you aj i'm good how are you so
good man he was giving you like nine
different [ __ ] names in fairness and
i folded it like an airplane so there it
is they'll do it so it's your [ __ ]
fault
thanks aj um uh once you ask this
question you could choose from one of
these fabulous prizes
we got some [ __ ] over here for you
that's equally as cool what can we do
you for um so
pop culture is basically taking over the
comic book scene right i mean um
different vice versa
or yeah the opposite um so in regards to
comic book properties can you give us
some of your pros and cons for
how some of the multimedia formats have
taken it and which ones do you have
good to say and bad to say about
in regards specifically
movies tv shows uh and my favorite uh
right now are video games
so can you kind of give us your take on
the various formats of media and how
they're relating
isn't that what we do on the whole show
i mean specific examples do you have a
specific example if it's easier if you
give us something that we can react to
otherwise it's a very wide field where
i'm like i like it all i mean clearly i
like it all my bar is very low so it'd
be helpful can you do a surprise one and
say video games
can you be even more specific there are
a lot of video games as well he could
probably talk about video games well way
more than me i don't really play well i
guess maybe um what is your favorite uh
comic book video game these days
or ever or ever ever
and then movie
and then tv show
you go first i'm lost
i'm really lost uh i think my my
favorite comic book video game yes or a
video game that's based on a comic book
property
is uh is the the batman arkham games yes
um
i think that i think rocksteady did the
thing which is make you feel like you're
batman um which hadn't been done before
well yeah
depressed welcome to the game your
parents are dead none more dark
um but it's it's the jack reacher of
video games which is all you
you just sold me was he walks into town
and curbs people to death just punches
everybody to death i'm [ __ ] buying me
an xbox tomorrow yeah you know that and
the the ps4 now ps5 version of
spider-man
um
people like that game questions
especially yeah but it's just the the
the feeling of swinging through a city
you know it's to certain degree it's
less the story and i like the story in
those games and it's less than anything
about the gameplay but it's more the
i'm feeling how it must feel like to be
spider-man
and the same way that batman is how it's
feeling to be batman which is i hang on
purchase i drop down and i punch a lot
of poor people to death
prisoners prisoners prince prisoners see
jack reacher he don't ask how much money
you got before he beat your ass he don't
care like were you in a bentley don't
give [ __ ] yeah we're gonna dotson just
as good rich poor he'll curb everybody i
will shoot you in the back
just because it's fun unbelievable if
you had told me
like flat out that's the show you're
going to watch and be like i'm not going
to like that and now
i want to live it i love it so much
i just want to hang out with reacher all
the time it wasn't adorable his mom
don't even call him by his name she also
calls it by the way
like you've got another son he's he's
joe
you you're a reacher but i'm nine
reacher and it's very like quippy like
great one-liners back and forth andy
mcauliffe is my friend i do education
with he uh read the books did you ever
read the books never did he was so i was
like did you watch this rejoice i'm
selling this creature to everybody and
he's like i know about the magic of
reacher and i was like if you watch the
show he's like i watch the first two
episodes and he's going let me tell you
something
i've never seen somebody adapt something
where they did not put their own style
or signature on it in the least he's
going that tv show is literally the
[ __ ] book the dialogue the situation
everything he's like it really captures
lee child's writing and he described his
writing he's like
he is like what so is the every book
because he's good like 20 books i was
like is every book he just bombs into a
town and [ __ ] trouble happens and
he's got to [ __ ] kill people and [ __ ]
he goes pretty much
and he's gone there's i was like is
there always some piece of [ __ ] like
[ __ ] town father son who's like all
right reach here and [ __ ] like that
some guy who like clearly shouldn't be
this full of himself he's like reacher
would [ __ ] kill you bro but still
he's like up in reacher's girl he goes
yeah there's always the [ __ ] son in
town and [ __ ] like that and he said that
in the book
the characters who like get up and reach
his face
he'll like lee childs will write a big
[ __ ] block of dialogue where it's
just like you listen here reach here
we're gonna kill you and skin you and
[ __ ] find everyone you love and it
looks like you and [ __ ] kill them
pull their [ __ ] out and [ __ ] they do
a big speech
and then right after that andy said like
then there's always a one-line paragraph
that just says reacher said nothing
well because reacher and i another
reason why i know you like it it's the
incredible hulk show yes
but i asked you who held it was both lou
ferreino and bill bexley at the same
time you [ __ ] nailed it i was trying
to explain it to ernie and ernie was
like it sounds like billy jack and i was
like i kind of is a little bit like
billy jack but billy jack lived in the
town he didn't bomb into town and [ __ ]
but he was always fighting some rich
[ __ ] and his piece of [ __ ] son who's
all mouthy it's crazy man how that trope
of the piece of [ __ ] son who's mouthy
still [ __ ] works i was outraged by
the villain i was so [ __ ] mad at this
kid i was like you were [ __ ] born on
third base acting like you hit a triple
you piece of [ __ ] and my wife is like
easy we have a daughter and i was like
you're right you're right
i also do like the lead child is a
pseudonym for a british writer yeah he's
a british guy yeah and this is clearly
what his idea of america is i love it
i want to live
and a giant mountain man who just swans
into town punching justice into people
and then leaves and you know what we
didn't say which is like probably the
[ __ ] most the biggest selling point
is like this show is so good
that ultimately like spoilers at the
heart of it is a counterfeit mystery and
[ __ ] you can't think of a more boring
[ __ ] crime but they made it so
[ __ ] sexy bro
i was suddenly like you could do that
with counterfeiting like [ __ ] count
me in i don't know what you're talking
about you're missing out on reacher my
friend that's [ __ ]
the height of comic book energy can i do
one more i have not seen an episode of
reacher yet you haven't seen it again
not yet come over my house let's watch
rachel together
smoke up and watch richard they should
do a reacher [ __ ] game man where he
just like comes to town curbs people and
[ __ ] she's like it's the most boring
game because you're automatically at the
upper max level of your character like
you show up in god mode and you just
you never find a boss because you are
the boss
you've got some [ __ ] problem to
solve like you got to put the squares
and the other squares like i know is
what the the grain feed was for you saw
the reacher go have sex with that lady
and it's done i really resent you making
sex a big part of it you know why
because there's no not kids at home it's
sex isn't as big a part of reading i
don't know he might have watched reach
or around her or something like that but
this reacher program does not have
nearly as much [ __ ] no the problem
was that they they build up roscoe as
this like
very formidable detective police officer
who's just no [ __ ] funny business
yeah and of course
she's a bond girl by the end of it which
is cheesy i cannot resist the power of
your giant corn fed penis jack reacher
that's when somebody else on twitter was
like do they put in as much about his
dick as he's in the books
i guess in the books like he's like he
reacher took down his [ __ ] giant [ __ ]
it would have to be big this dude's a
mountain i mean it's a [ __ ] ant i'm
pretty sure just this giant tree
that has little meetings with other
giant trees
she asked can i see it reacher pulled
out a baby's arm holding an apple
reacher said nothing
reacher said nothing anyway um so that's
the batman game batman game of the
spiderman game
are all my favorite comic book-based
games
and the the the hitherto uh yet
developed reacher game yes forthcoming
the last uh movie or comic book oriented
video game i think i remember playing
was
i was it super nintendo did the death of
superman
does anybody remember this game 64
superman which one n64 superman yes that
was it you're talking about the game
that killed video games for comic books
it did
it was that bad is that no you're
talking about the atari superman game
not the [ __ ] death of superman game i
played that game was dope why would it
have killed things because it literally
told the story of the death of superman
like
oh it wasn't that one yeah no i know i
think i know the one you're talking
about i've seen a video of that this was
actually the graphics are pretty good
for its time and stuff and it took you
through the entire death of superman's
storyline including obviously [ __ ]
fighting uh what's his [ __ ] doomsday
doomsday and then uh coming back they
had all the supermans represented so you
came back as uh cyborg superman you came
back as steel you came back as superboy
and it followed the storyline incredibly
well this is going back like over 20
[ __ ] years ago maybe 25 years ago um
which shows you how much video games i
actually play but i loved that game my
all-time favorite video game though and
this probably i'll get roasted on
[ __ ] by video game twitter or whoever
else is
[ __ ] hasn't come from my pound of
flesh yet but there was this [ __ ]
awesome sega genesis bullwinkle and
rocky game which i loved and sometimes i
wake up in the morning and be like i
wish i still had that game
it really followed the plot of those
cartoons insanely well and i was a huge
bullwinkle fan so can i introduce you to
my friend ebay
who will guess i could make will happily
bring you a sega genesis and a
bullwinkle game that's true that's true
but sometimes things live better in your
memory right like i remember being like
[ __ ] clash of the titans was great man
shut the [ __ ] up
don't even the original i'm talking
about
the one that we had in our child the
only one when was the last time you
watched it like two weeks ago it's a
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is great it's a tough
set dude all the harry house and stuff
is great booboo's great but a lot of it
is a tough [ __ ] sith i remember it
more fondly than when i watched it i was
like ooh where's the booboo know who you
are
um did that answer a question
thank you [ __ ] give it up for aj
ladies and gentlemen you want a poster
and he wants some 40x tickets
thank you my friend
pleasure
you know what movie i watched recently
tell me
super getting awfully comfortable like
tell me bring it in
superman four the quest for peace the
quest for peace why what made you watch
it i i took part in a thing called
screen drafts
where it's you know competitive movie
ranking and they were doing a draft uh
that i did last night for six hours
draft like football draft kind of like
just putting them in order and we did
the batman versus superman draft last
night ranking every movie that had
batman or superman as a lead character
oh [ __ ] eye um i can't say who won
because that that's their [ __ ]
present to unwrap right don't spoil it i
won't spoil it but watching superman 4
again which i had previously thought was
the worst superman movie ever made
not as bad as i thought it was right
like the first [ __ ] within the last 15
years and i remember being like saying
that yeah i mean it falls off a cliff
actually i think first half i think it's
better than three i think it's better
than three two yeah because
and if you haven't seen in a while i'm
not sure if you guys remember this but
it's superman doesn't like nukes
and uh and like gets rid of all the
nukes he gives a pretty moving speech
when he stands before it was a congress
or whatever he goes to the u.s uh the
u.n and he's just like so from
henceforth i'm going to take all the
[ __ ] nuclear weapons and pitch them
into the scene yeah like but it's it's
unlike a lot of the other superman
movies specifically superman three
there's a real moral question
that's at the center of it yeah which is
do i have the right to do this
i can i'm [ __ ] superman and nobody
can stop me
but can i fix this thing can i solve the
unsolvable crime
and and he does and that's kind of
that's that's part of what i loved about
the grant morrison superman all-star
superman run is part of what i love
about mark wade's version of superman
which is
the the tragedy of superman we've talked
about it before is that he can't solve
every problem right you can't be
everywhere at once like joe reacher
remember reacher's mom says joe
you can't solve every problem you can't
solve every problem but they try anyway
yeah and it's the trying that makes him
a hero
and so the first half hour of that movie
is actually really really strong and
christopher reeve is never not invested
yeah in playing well he co-wrote the
story yeah
it was very much like i'm going to come
back into a fourth one it's going to be
it's going to say something that i want
to say right which is nukes are awful
but that dude always shows up even in
the [ __ ] fight with nuclear man with
gene hackman's voice for reasons
um
he does that the nuclear man is gene
hackman's voice yeah it's so weird
so weird and hackman came back he did
yeah and again didn't half step any of
it like he's like if i'm showing up i'm
gonna be gene hackman
it's a watchable flick i'm glad you came
to that conclusion yeah so that's it
slight digression to my weird ass last
night movie i got a digression to make
too and it would be too long to look up
the tweet that i liked but fairly
recently on twitter every once in a
while
you know somebody comes up with a very
hot take on batman where they're like
you know growing up is the day you
realize that
bruce wayne could have done more money
for you know put it could have put his
money into the homeless rather than
you know [ __ ] beat up criminals and
[ __ ] like that
so you know it's
it's it's a
pretty standard
[ __ ] take that you know eliminates
the fun and fantasy of a world with
[ __ ] superheroes in it [ __ ] and i
think grant morrison wrote a very
eloquent piece
in response about like i don't want to
live in that world like i the
superheroes are what we turn to
you know to forget about the [ __ ]
real world so like why you know do i
want to tell a story about what batman
could do with his wealth he does in the
comics you know the wayne foundation
gives money to a bunch of [ __ ] but he
also does this
and so somebody on twitter
uh oh
i can't uh it would be too long to find
it it's on my laptop though this guy had
this like screaming [ __ ] take at this
where he goes this
is the worst [ __ ] take i've ever read
he was going um
what was the exact word he goes
um
he goes you know yes
you can give your money to charity
but then sometimes some homicidal clown
is poisoning the water
what do you do then
and that was great enough but then he
put a [ __ ] second tweet where he was
just like
jesus christ he's going i can't [ __ ]
believe people are still talking about
this he's going bruce wayne gives a lot
of money to [ __ ] charity all the time
and stuff he's always helping out with
programs he's going but like
sometimes
kg beast is going [ __ ] crazy in your
town
and low-income housing will not solve
the problem
oh i [ __ ] loved it man so much that i
caught my wife in the room i said come
here you got to hear this
she didn't think it was nearly as funny
but [ __ ]
what a brilliant the fact that he chose
kg beast and low income housing made me
laugh so [ __ ] hard
anyway back to you jc banff man we got
one last questioner yeah i just want to
point it out point out my favorite video
game yeah which wasn't the best video
game but it came with a
red cartridge was maximum carnage oh i
played that i [ __ ] loved that game
i remember that game that was a really
good game too that followed the [ __ ]
storyline very closely and for the day
the graphics were pretty [ __ ]
wonderful yeah that was
to the death of superman i would agree
with that it followed the storyline and
the graphics were good enough for the
time and stuff and andrew wanted me to
point out that last of mohegans is
screening
uh this friday at the new bev oh [ __ ]
an actual print of it
wow we can have all of our questions
answered simply by going to that movie
what night is it uh friday the 25th
friday 2 p.m friday at 2
um hey since we're all plugging [ __ ]
saturday night february 26th which is
this saturday night at flappers comedy
club over in burbank me and ralph doing
hollywood babylon as the four-year
anniversary heart attack show four years
ago
on that day i [ __ ] nearly died
so
um if you haven't got tickets already
pick up tickets at seaspot.com this can
be a fun [ __ ] show uh i might be
going to see
uh last the mohicans first though
you should
actually i'll probably just stream it
i need my house
and that's how they get you um all right
man give us our last question i
apologize again for the names like i
always put a space between my first name
and last name but people aren't doing
that tonight
uh this is eric zahn eric
erickson
give it up for erickson man
[Applause]
it's so weird i didn't put together that
you were erickson i just thought you
were like oh i know how to pronounce
that
but it's because you are let me see that
sleeve man is that [ __ ] wonder woman
right there
it's the whole justice league i'm
waiting i still haven't gotten flash yet
bring it up to this camera right here
the jc camera go to the front jason show
them how to do it yeah move up closer i
i'm not that tall
but but bro lift your arm up just have
to lift your arm i'm about to step on
the peacemaker box you all you have to
do is lift your arm that's cool shamans
they can see the detail and stuff
as
well they can't see it but that's very
nice
it's i'm in the room and i'm telling you
it's [ __ ] nice
um well done man [ __ ] you married to
that justice league forever
uh so my question is because i just want
to be up here
um
which character would you make into an
action star charlie brown
kailu
calvin from calvin hans
you know what what a great question give
it up for that question ladies and
gentlemen
all right
we have three choices
to turn a children's uh star into an
action hero first choice is charlie
brown yes second one is how do you
pronounce it i always said callaloo but
it's call you
the canadian bald kid who's like
charlotte canadian charlie brown also
bald
and then the third one is calvin from
calvin
read it every day in the newspaper um
he's got pissing on the back of every
pickup truck
yes
that's true um all right
well calvin and hobbes you get to play
at a [ __ ] crazy angle right
because like he can be [ __ ] kicking
ass and he's constantly being told to do
so by the tiger nobody can see and [ __ ]
hobbs is just like stop get why don't
you curb that [ __ ]
that's why i reached your seat
in your heart
um so that's cool
uh
cal cali who like he gets killed in the
first 10 minutes of any action movie
but you do have a [ __ ] you got an
argument with charlie brown because
this this is like
falling down
yeah you know what i'm saying like [ __ ]
a [ __ ] push to the edge
everybody always [ __ ] on him pulling
footballs having parties without him
he's always the last [ __ ] secondary
thought and [ __ ] like that his dog
doesn't respect him and [ __ ] and we all
know that dogs don't live very long so
that snoopy dog is dead so he's got
[ __ ] grief in his life and [ __ ] no
respect anywhere a man like that snaps
man
and then you got charlie rambo right
there
people keep on asking me if i'm back and
i haven't known how to answer that but
yeah i'm thinking i'm gonna kick that
[ __ ] ball yes
absolutely man and the money's about to
put some [ __ ] [ __ ] to death
he's like do you got any last words and
they're like
wow
[Laughter]
i'm choosing charlie brown man
see imagine the poster it's just that
zigzag shirt but it's got blood on it
and [ __ ]
people like oh i'm there this is the
reach
yes [ __ ] it absolutely
i mean all i want now is the charlie
brown gang
because now it's get him linus and lana
shows up with his [ __ ] nunchuck
blanket
oh he's just strangling [ __ ] yeah pops
up behind him and [ __ ] strangles him
to death and he's like charlie brown i
like to look in their eyes and watch the
light go out yeah no that's that's
marcy's job mark the great pumpkin
[ __ ]
marcy just comes up real quiet like i
got him sir
and just the the miracles marcy's the
man in the chair clearly like [ __ ]
the person that's like sir you're gonna
go over here sir you're going to go over
here she's the guy in the van yes
absolutely she's the [ __ ] brains of
the operation do the dance sequence of
them just beating someone else well i'll
tell you right now to answer an earlier
question this is the show where you do a
[ __ ] opening dance number with all
the peanuts slaughtering [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
so you just call it p nuts but nuts is
in capital letters
and it's got a z
[Laughter]
i mean listen not for nothing we can go
to netflix tomorrow and sell this
i know the folks at wild brain they make
all the current peanut stuff they do the
snoopy show on apple tv and stuff which
is adorable if you've not watched it
check it out
i say we go pitch this to them like i
swear to god a new take on this [ __ ] no
like you realize charles schultz left a
bunch of things he said that we can't do
with these characters i was like but i
bet you he never thought of this [ __ ]
yeah oh it's not actually peanuts but
it's totally peanuts it's peanut it's a
bald kid and a zigzag shirt yeah and we
are they're children or are they
grown-ups no they're children i think
they're still [ __ ] children [ __ ] yeah
it's like hit girl man like [ __ ] like
a whole series of kids killing [ __ ]
and [ __ ] you know and like it's richer
with children that's my pitch
and the inciting incident is snoopy gets
killed by some [ __ ] adult who's
driving their car it's john wick john
wick with [ __ ] peanuts
[Laughter]
oh that's [ __ ] awesome
and then but the ghost of snoopy is
haunting you could you you could do that
as a cheap [ __ ] series too because
once you get rid of the dog that dances
the budget comes way the [ __ ] down
so if snoopy gets killed in the first
act and [ __ ] this show costs like a buck
05 to make we can make a series every
month of this show
deliver what the people want when they
want exactly blood thirsty bald kid
[ __ ] taking [ __ ] out and [ __ ]
ch chat what about woodstock
season two no
woodstock is death from above
chat
chat's calling the show falling brown
falling brown
jeff's kiss to the chest man
that is going [ __ ] brown that's so
good that's the name of the show and the
name of the porn
[Laughter]
um that was an amazing question it got a
great answer give it up for him ladies
and gentlemen he won a poster
erickson
poster and 40 tickets well done man
that brought a lot of joy
say again
yeah you have to just both yeah no
choice can't give to the white guy
if you're gonna dapper bro you gotta
grab a bro that's all i'm saying
chad is lighting up with like oh [ __ ]
mark
everything's about race
um everything's not about race here on
[ __ ] fat man beyond everything's
about [ __ ] loving some [ __ ]
though unless it's a great race
it is the great race
death race charlie brown where they kill
a bunch of white supremacists that's the
great race fallen
ladies and gentlemen have you had a good
time this evening
i cannot thank you enough for coming up
what a wonderful return is this the
first live show of 2022 or 2022 yeah the
first time we've been in the bar since
the beginning of the year uh [ __ ]
welcome back folks thanks for selling us
out thanks for being here good to be
back we don't uh
we don't get to do a show without a
place to do it give it up for jc and the
scum and villainy candina
[Applause]
give it up for the man from kentucky
andrew ladies and gentlemen
but we all know this is true there is no
show without the man sitting to my
standing to my [ __ ] left give it up
for the marvelous mark bernard and
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
and that is fat man beyond for this week
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard tune in
next week same fat time same fat
channels podcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
everybody good night wow
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith